um so this annual meeting of the council
my first remind all of you of some
domestic Arrangements
toilets are situated outside the meeting
room opposite the church stairs cold
water is also available in the breakout
area outside the meeting room
if the fire alarm should sound please
leave the meeting room by following the
fire exit signs and meet on the Ipswich
Town Football Club training pitch
do not re-enter the building until you
are told it is safe to do so
please switch off all mobile phones or
turn them to silent
I would like to remind everyone present
that this meeting will be broadcast live
to the internet
and will be capable of repeated viewing
the whole of the meeting will be filmed
except whether a confidential or exempt
items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed
by entering this meeting you are also
consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting and or training purposes
the council members of the public and
the Press May record film photograph or
broadcast this meeting when the public
and the Press are not lawfully excluded
before I move on to the agenda I would
like to take this opportunity to say a
few words
welcome members to the chamber and to
the first meeting of our new term
sadly this is the last meeting that I
will be opening as chairman of baber
District Council
I have as I think many of the members
from the last term will know love the
role and found it a great privilege to
chair these meetings and represent the
council externally
I think we have had a good and
productive term as a council
accomplishing many important things
including supporting our district during
covid
I gave my thanks to officers and fellow
councilors at our last meeting
my final donation to The Blossom appeal
formally presented to Ipswich hospital
last week reached 12
408 pounds
so I'm proud to say that baber District
Council and many Associates contributed
towards the new Breast Care Center at
the hospital
I hope none of you or your loved ones
need to use it
and so have a new set of counselors with
some familiar faces
congratulations to all of you for your
success in the election
I wish us all a successful new term
and to the new chairman
I hope you enjoy your term as much as I
did and I offer you all my good wishes
support and help should you need it
I'll move on to the agenda now
election of care of the council
police can I have nominations for the
position of chair of the council
councilor plum
thank you
yeah yeah I'm happy to second that
nomination
thank you madam chairman
members I'd like I would like to propose
councilor Margaret maybe she's been a
counselor for some time
and it worked very hard and he's
dedicated and her attendance record is
very good
she also campaigned against any increase
in car parking charges for the residents
and businesses people of baber District
we conservatives support no car parking
increases I asked you to support this
also and support Margaret maybe for
chairman thank you
thank you can I have a second please
thank you
um in that case we will go to
um an electronic vote to conduct the
vote
so chair just to explain so we're taking
the first nomination that's for
councilor melvisi to be the chair of the
council if the vote is 17 or more we
will take it that councilor melvisi has
been duly elected if it's a split or it
goes um 17
it would take that if it's any different
then we'll come back and do the second
vote is that okay so we're going to vote
at the moment for the nomination for
cancer Mel BC so you need to vote for if
you want to to put her in and against if
you don't
electronic vote is now set in blue for
you to cast your vote
so Council of Court can I take your vote
please yes for councilor melvisi thank
you
and Council Grandin can I take your vote
for councilman easy thank you
are there any other cancers having
K cancer Osborne
cancer Jameson
yeah four Council of Mel Weezy
councilor Davis
you managed it
yeah cancer beer
I'm for Margaret Mabry
anymore
oh my God
councilor Newman
tonight okay
cancer clover
yeah we've got them all okay no that's
fine we've got everybody's vote now so
we just do a tally up
treatment
okay so chair that is 23 votes for
eight against and one abstention
I declare Council malfeasy the new
chairman of paper District Council
let's see how
foreign
[Music]
okay
I Elizabeth maldizi having been elected
to the office of chair of the council
hereby declare that I take that office
upon myself
and will duly and Faithfully fulfill the
duties of it according to the best of my
judgment and ability
I undertake to be guided by the Suffolk
code of conduct in the performance of my
functions in that office
I'll now sign the form
well good evening councilors and thank
you very very much
um
I didn't think I was appreciated quite
as much as is evident by the vote
um
I ask that you join you join a vote of
thanks to the outgoing chair councilor
Grandin
for delivering above and beyond during
what was a demanding emotional roller
coaster of a year
for us all and in particular for
Catherine
so Catherine well done
[Applause]
you now deserve a rest
congratulations to all who were elected
and to those who were returned
but we shall not forget the contribution
made by those counselors who were not
returned and who had given the Council
on stinting loyalty and commitment
the sum total of their contribution is
that they take home
150 years of experience and knowledge
and probably
just for being then
at this point it's usual for the
incoming chair to inform council members
of those Charities they might wish to
support during their term
unfortunately at this juncture I'm not
able to share the precise Charities but
suffice to say that they will in all
probability be connected to male Mental
Health
male suicide and child sexual abuse
thank you
I would now like to move to item two on
the agenda which is the election of the
vice chair of the council so please can
I have your nominations
counselor Jameson
thank you chair I'd like to nominate
councilor Simon Dowling for vice chair
thank you
we have a seconder
councilor plum
are there any further nominations
councilor Mayberry
thank you very much Madam chairman I
would like to propose the vice chair
Brian Riley who has a wealth of
experience under his belt and I'm sure
we'll do a splendid job and he assures
me that he
although he's not a man of action he's a
man of words
thank you very much you have a second up
counselor
I'm gonna get it Clover okay super thank
you I do apologize but some of you are
very new so
yes we'll just plod on through together
um thank you chair so because we have
two nominations we will be taking the
first nomination which is councilor
Simon Dowling so if you'd like to cast
your votes that is now showing in blue
all right okay that's good
Casa Grande
councilor Osborne
councilor Jameson oh
cancer Sally Davis
that's a beer
yes
thank you chair the votes are 24 4
cancer Simon darling seven against and
one abstention 24
. I declare accounts I therefore declare
counselor Dowling being duly elected as
Vice chair
I would now invite the vice chair to
come forward and sign the acceptance of
office after having read it
foreign
haven't been elected to the office of
Vice chair of the council hereby declare
on myself and will Julie and Faithfully
fulfill the duties of it according to
the best of my judgment and ability
I undertake to be guided by the Suffolk
code of conduct in the performance of my
functions of that office
[Applause]
thank you
on
and done this before
how's that I think I will is that all
right
can I say a few words
um ladies and gentlemen I want to thank
you very much for your faith in me I
shall do my very best to execute it
um you'll forgive me as an English
teacher thinking of my favorite writer
uh two short quotations uh from Twelfth
Night
some are born to Greatness some achieve
greatness some have greatness thrust
upon them and the other quotation from
him with the fourth part two uneasy lies
the head that wears a crown
so on I shall be careful thank you very
much
[Applause]
thank you chair none received thank you
now we come to Declaration of Interest
by councilors are there any declarations
nope
thank you
um item five BC forward slash 23 forward
slash one to confirm the minutes of the
meeting held on the 22nd of March 2023
this is for accuracy only
however are there any issues with
accuracy
and if there are none can I please have
a proposer followed by a second a
council award proposing a councilor
holds seconding thank you very much we
now intend to carry out this vote by a
show of hands
so
all those in favor
against any abstentions
vote in favor first
okay
right is it yeah
and then the abstentions you need to
meet where you can go to yourself
any abstentions
okay
I'm advised that's carried
now we come to item six on the agenda
which is the election of the leader of
the council
may I have nomination for leader of the
council
councilor Jameson
uh thank you madam chair just before I
nominate my proposal for the leader I'd
just like to say that I feel we produce
an exciting and interesting form of
leadership
that will enable the council to provide
a truly coherent and collaborative
Administration
by sharing and rotating the leadership
we're actually delivering the former
Council that the electorate of Baylor
have voted for
one that works to go for the benefit
rather than for their benefit rather
than the one that puts party first
we know the green members will be looked
at closely over the course of the next
four years and we want to show that not
only do we bring fresh places to the
council but we bring
for new ideas as well and with that I'd
like to pose councilor Busby's leader
the intention is that the term for the
leader will be one year I would ask the
management officer to bring the report
to the next full Council to make the
necessary change to the labor District
Council Constitution
okay
so now need a second can I have a
seconder for that please
councilor plum
thank you any further nominations for
leader of the council
we now intend to carry this out carry
out this vote by a show of hands so all
in favor
yeah okay
right any abstentions
thank you
you're not allowed any against
okay
okay I can confirm that the vote has
been carried in favor of councilor Busby
I wanted
to declare
he has a declaration as well
he's due re-elected by an answer okay I
therefore announced they declare that
councilor Busby is duly elected as
leader of baber District Council
[Applause]
I come now to item seven BC forward
slash 23 forward slash two
announcements from the chairman and
leader
now I refer you to paper BC 24 23
forward slash two simply for noting
councilor Busby would you like to make
any announcements
being Jewish
I had no ambition to become leader but
I'm honored to represent you
and I promise to do my best however
this isn't about me
about you
twenty five thousand six hundred and
thirteen residents voted for you to work
on their behalf to ensure that we
deliver the best for favor that we can
and Well Done John now
for getting the most votes out of any
less 1069 some of us can dream of those
numbers
14 of you are new to the process welcome
to the challenges that lie ahead as well
for us to succeed in our endeavors and
please note the name of the building
that you're in
we will need to work diligently and
together
we have many challenges climate change
and housing energy inefficiencies
numerous ugly infrastructure projects
changes to waste collection The Joint
local plan inappropriate housing
developments through volume size and
location struggling High streets
High Cost of Living and inflationary
pressures on our services
unlike mid-suffer we don't have huge
reserves to call upon to help us to
deliver Solutions and in fact you'll be
frequently reminded of the financial
challenges that we face
fortunately we have a great team of
officers to assist us and I recommend
that you lean on them
certainly not me and if um just point
them out to you if you'd like to stand
so that the new members can get a look
at you Kathy Kathy Nixon is the Deputy
Chief exec thank you and then Sarah
Wilcox who's got one of the worst titles
director of customers digital
transformation and improvements
Emily Emily attack director of assets
and Investments
and then Mark Ames director of
operations
director of economic growth and climate
change
last but not least
Melissa Evans who's the director of
corporate resources and section one five
officer and in charge of the money
thank you so
no excuses now you know who they are and
what they do
with no party getting anywhere near a
majority congratulations to the greens
for polling 31 of the votes we will have
to continue to work as a coalition
Coalition but after all it is the Baylor
way
group leaders have devised a unique plan
for the four years and thank you Lee for
standing like I'm trying to explaining
it all to everybody
um we're going to rotate on an annual
basis I will do the first year debessor
for the greens will do the second and
fourth and John
John III
and that's my first action I would like
to appoint Debra saw and John Ward as
Deputy political leaders
together we will leave the cabinet of
eight four greens three Independents and
one lib Dem
we'll be announcing the other cabinet
members in their portfolio shortly
and just lastly a big thank you to John
Ward
who has done this post for the last five
years is far too clever by half so don't
expect too much from me thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much councilor Busby I
now look to councilor saw
and Council award
to make
to say a few words councilors or would
you like to go first thank you madam
chair
um I think we are all ambitious for our
district and we all want to do the best
for our residents and our communities I
think this is a a very exciting and
Innovative approach one that I'm sure
will get a lot of attention from other
councils around the country
um I think we start off uh working on
our priorities our joint priorities
together but I know we're all United
with one purpose which is the
Prosperity success well-being of our
residents and their communities thank
you thank you very much
[Applause]
Council award
thank you chairman
I wish to congratulate councilor Busby
on his election as leader of the council
it is a great responsibility and
privilege to hold that office and I'm
sure he'll be a great Ambassador for
baber
I'm particularly pleased that we have
green Innovative Coalition arrangement
for the council the consensus that will
be needed to make that Coalition work
will be necessary as we Face our biggest
challenges I know Council of Busby has
articulated some of those but in the
short term we do have some really
pressing ones
such as improving and retrofitting our
housing stock to meet our energy saving
commitments the resources and waste
strategy from the government
particularly the recycling consistency
component and its impact on our waste
operations
planning policy in the joint local plan
and of course the other pressure
ever-present pressures on our budgets I
look forward to working with councils
Busby and saw to make the Coalition a
strong one that delivers excellent
services for our residents and
businesses
we now move on to item eight on the
agenda which is the designation of
committees and joint committees now we
will treat these in in Block
um therefore could I have a proposer to
appoint all the Committees listed on the
agenda
councilor Plum and a seconder please
councilor Lee Parker
um
will now carry this out Bible show of
hands yes so those in favor please
sorry counselor could I just ask a
question I haven't seen the list because
as you know I've got a brand new
computer and we can't make it work
between us all so is it possible that I
can I'll read them out
so we have overview and scrutiny
committee
the ever wonderful planning committee
sorry madam chairman
we're just accepting that these are the
Committees
then the allocation of people we have to
do the political breakdown thingy first
and then you move to actually putting
people in
um
yeah we'll do that later
okay so we're looking at overview and
scrutiny as a committee planning
committee Licensing and Regulatory
committee joint audit and standards
committee and Joint appointments
committee
so
I've got a proposal and a seconder so
can we take a vote of those in favor of
having these committees
yeah I think that's unanimous yeah thank
you very much councilors
carried
the next one on item nine on the agenda
is the political balance and composition
of committees
so I refer you to appendix B in the
tabled papers and would like to invite
the monitoring officer to introduce
paper BC forward slash 23 forward slash
three
thank you madam chair
um the rationale for the for the paper
is that the section is 15 to 17 of the
local government housing act 1989
require the council to follow rules in
regards to secure political balance on
its various subcommittees and committees
political groups for the purpose of the
ACT should not be confused with
political parties the formula and
determine the entitlement can get a
little bit complicated but at the end of
the day
what it boils down to is that the other
main committees allocated to a political
group and they must bear some
relationships with the total membership
thank you very much
excuse me
could I have a proposer and a seconder
please
proposing Council Holt seconding
councilor Mayberry thank you very much
do we have any questions on this
foreign
I do intend to carry out the vote by a
show of hands
so no questions no okay all those in
favor please
thank you very much are there any
abstentions no
that is now carried item 10 is the
election of chairs and vice chairs of
committees
so
it has to be noted that in accordance
with the council's Constitution Article
6 Open Bracket
6.2.1 close bracket the leader shall
take up chairmanship of the cabinet
but we now need to elect a chair and
vice chair for the following committees
overview and scrutiny
planning committee Licensing and
Regulatory committee I'll come back to
you counselor Mabry
okay
councilor Mabry
thank you very much Madam chairman
um I would like to um to propose Brian
Council Brian Riley for chairman of
overview and scrutiny I'm I'm assuming
Madam chairman that we're taking each
one into yes we are so that is my first
okay thank you very much thank you do
you have a seconder
councilor beer
are there any other nominations for
overview in scrutiny councilor plum
councilor McLaren and a seconder
councilor Lee Parker okay how are we
doing this um we're doing electronic
teachers so we're doing the vote
electronically
um so chair will take the first
nomination first which is councilor
Brian Riley all those in favor of
councilor Brian Riley as chair of
committee if you'd like to cast your
votes now he's not alive yet
refresh
yeah okay let me take the thing off it's
gone off is it okay
okay let's do it by Chef Hansen and so
all those in favor of councilor Brian
Riley if you'd like to put your hands up
seven okay
all those in favor of councilor Mary
McLaren put your hands up
okay
right
overview and scrutiny committee chair
no no no no no no it's just I'm putting
my words around differently
okay overview and scrutiny committee
chair is Mary McLaren
well done Mary
we now need a vice chair for the
committee councilor Parker
yeah thank you madam chair I would like
to propose councilor John Wyman for vice
chairman
for councilor Wyman
councilor Jameson
thank you
we have any other nominations for vice
chair of overview in scrutiny
no I think we're having a meeting over
here
can I have a vote then please
all those in favor of councilor Wyman
thank you very much
all those against
nope cancel appear okay I declare that
the vice chair for overview and scrutiny
is councilor Wyman
thank you very much we now come to the
planning committee can I have a
nominations for chair councilor John
Ward
thank you do you have a seconder
councilor Parker
do we have any other nominations
councilor Glover
I'd like to nominate Peter beer
you have a seconder
Mark Newman yeah okay we're doing this
electronically
okay we'll do we'll
yeah so um votes for councilor Plum
please all those in favor
and those against
that's carried
councilor plum you're now chairman of
planning committee
congratulations can we have nominations
for the vice chair
again Madame sure I'd like to pose
councilor Helen Davis for the position
of Vice chair thank you okay do you have
a second
plum
we have any other nominations for vice
chair
okay we'll move to a vote show of hands
all in favor
thank you
and against
are you abstaining
councilor Mayberry is your group
abstaining or are they voting against
them
um
Madame chairman
they have their own free will and I
think they are abstaining thank you
uh chair and vice chair of Licensing and
Regulatory committees
the Jameson
I'd like to nominate councilor Parker
for chair councilor Parker yeah okay
thank you and do you have us do we have
a second counselor plum
do we have any other nominations for
licensing yes I'd like to nominate Paul
Clover please
okay in the second uh
okay councilor beer right
we'll do a show of hands for the first
nominee
so who's in favor of councilor Parker
show their hands please
okay I think that's carried
we now have to move to Vice chair of
Licensing regulatory so do I have any
proposers
councilor plum
councilor Jameson thank you very much do
we have a second for that nomination
councilor Parker do we have any other
nominations for vice chair
can I have a show of hands please in
favor
thank you
we now move on to elect a co-chair for
the following joint committees
joint audit and standards committee
joint appointments committee
may I have a nomination for the chair of
overview well I've done a review
I've lost the police there
overview is good together
page 14.
right
um
all right
[Applause]
okay
that's page 13. and it's different
may I have the nomination for co-chair
of the joint
joint audit and standards committee
councilor Jameson
I would like to nominate councilor Brian
Herron
Bryn Huron councilor plum
councilor Mabry
thank you madam chairman um I would like
to nominate Isabel Reese who has a
wealth of
stuff that's under her hat as it were
and I'm sure she'd do an absolutely
marvelous job so my number nomination is
Isabel Reese thank you
and a seconder please
thank you
thank you very much again we'll go buy a
show of hands dealing with the first
nomination
and then the second
so can I have a show of hands in favor
of councilor Huron as chair
cute
can I have a show of hands of those in
against
or any abstentions
sorry
I therefore declare that councilor Bryn
Huron is co-chair of joint audit and
standards committee
may I have nominations for the co-chair
of the joint appointments committee
Council award
oh sorry cancel a beer
um councilor Margaret Mabry
thank you a seconder
counselor Glover thank you
Council award
councilor Jameson I'm sorry madam
chairman but would councilor would be on
his feet please
sorry I didn't hear that
Madam chairman I asked if councilor Ward
would stand on
I'm sorry addressing you uh you're quite
correct Castle Mabry I apologize for not
pulling councilors up okay
Jameson okay thank you
councilor plum
the first nomination was counselor
councilor Mayberry
so can we have a show of hands in favor
okay
do I go for those against girlfriends
hi can I have a show of hands those
against
right
I'm afraid that's lost can I have a show
of hands for counselor Jameson
and those against
right councilor Jameson is there for the
co-chair of joint appointments committee
[Applause]
because
we don't I said okay where we've got two
names in only one place we're gonna have
to do
thank you for your patience counselors
um we now move to BC forward slash 23
forward slash four appointments to
outside bodies for the year
2023-24 I refer you to appendix a in the
tabled papers and would like to invite
the leader to introduce the paper
and move the recommendation in the
report however
we do have two
items where we have
more
nominations than we have spaces for
counselor
um
to Jan a list of our
proposals for this and I'm sorry to say
that one has been missed off on this
list and there's one on another so when
it comes to Suffolk Health scrutiny
I'm proposing myself
and I have been on this committee before
and I would like to
and that sadly has been left off because
it was given earlier
um
these things happen so it's just the
Suffolk Health
on this paper it is just a second house
through to me on this one okay thank you
all right thank you we'll take those
three
the items where we've got over subscribe
subscribe okay so we have three items
that are over subscribed
to move the paper
right so Council of Busby can you move
the paper so that we can accept it and
then we can move on to the elections
yes I'd like to move the paper so we can
get on to the elections
yes so do do you
is that okay yeah that's fine
and yeah and can have you got a seconder
cancel award thank you very much
and then we have
Association for Suffolk museums
we have John Nunn and Isabel Reese so we
need to go to a vote
those in favor of
Isabel Reese
go for another
info or do I have to get the um
um and who can I have a show of hands
for those in favor of John Nunn
thank you very much
John nun is appointed thank you we then
move on to gainsborough's house Society
well I think everybody wants to be a
member of that one
um
we have nominations for Laura Smith so
can I have a show of hands for Laura
Smith
okay yeah
I then have a nomination for Adrian
Osborne
can I have a show of hands please
okay
and then we have Margaret Mabry can have
a show of hands please
Adrian Osborne
is nominated as the representative for
gainsborough's house Society
thank you very much
the next one is Suffolk Health scrutiny
committee
where we have
a nomination by Margaret Mabry councilor
Mayberry
so all those in favor of councilor Mabry
please show your hands
thank you very much
what's the night
um cancerous Council Busby all right
okay
yeah
the other nominee is Mary McLaren can I
have a show of hands in favor of Mary
McLaren please
21. okay I declare that Mary McLaren is
representative on the
Suffolk
Health scrutiny committee
the last one
actually look under Suffolk how
spiritually it actually asks for a sub
as well
so you can make councilor Mabry
would you be happy to be the substitute
councilor Mayberry Madam chairman I have
enjoyed my time on health scrutiny and
as I said to council award the other day
every time I go to one of these meetings
I encourage the partnership between the
NHS and District councils so I would
love to do this sub and not that I wish
any ill on Mary but if she doesn't want
to get wish to go I will be delighted to
go thank you
okay Council I need you to show your
hands in favor of councilman Mabry being
the substitute for this committee
[Applause]
Western Suffolk Community whoever felt
successful
right we have another one that we have
to vote on which is Western Suffolk
Community safety partnership
um we need one candidate just like we've
just had and one substitute so can I
have your votes in favor of Daniel
Potter
sorry I can't see the names on it can we
have the names first please because they
were sort of voting I can't see where
the names are
it's probably me but on your form yeah
probably but you're on are you online
oh it's Daniel Potter and Margaret Mabry
thank you and we'll go through the
nominations yeah
right those in favor of Daniel Potter
okay
and then we have councilor Margaret
Mabry those in favor
councilor Owen do you wish to vote
[Laughter]
so actually
okay so again
um
the majority vote was for Daniel Potter
so that's been carried councilor Mabry
would you wish to be the sub on this one
as well uh Madam chairman I have a few
years under my belt with this
partnership and I'm going to be very
serious now I have been laughing I have
been smiling because I think that's what
we should be doing at Castle especially
tonight but this is a very serious
matter and I'm sure you're all aware of
the two murders that took place within
my ward for domestic abuse and it's
something that will come up
um to be reviewed in this partnership so
yes I would very much like to be the
suffer that and whilst I'm on my feet I
hope everyone here knows what to do if
they think someone is in danger
councilor Davis
yeah I think I need to point out that
I'm currently the chair of the western
partnership
and it's something that moves on so I'm
not quite sure why this has been brought
up as an outside body
um the chair is elected not being
elected for for two years in fact I'm
sure one of the directors might be able
to put shed light on it and in terms of
the DHR that's already been underway and
I'm part of that DHR writing and dealing
with that so I think there's um yeah I
think there's been a bit of a mix I
think
apart being advised that it is the
council's de certain it's the council's
responsibility and therefore their
decision to nominate their
representative on that body
so
I don't know maybe we can take it out of
this meeting and clarify understanding
yes
thank you very much now I've got to find
where I am in the whole in the process
the proceedings
I need
counselors I need you to confirm that
you accept councilor Mabry as the
substitute for
the Western Suffolk Community safety
partnership okay
okay
and the rest of the
bodies or panels
as tables
did we have a proposal
so now we've had the proposer and
seconder so I now need Council
counselors to vote on accepting the rest
of the or noting the rest of the um
document is it just noting
it is we do need to vote on it yeah
all in favor please show your hands
you have a question councilor McGraw
yeah I noticed there are still some
substitute members on the list unfilled
I'm assuming that can be done
subsequently I just like clarification
on that point
a deputy sorry
um just to clarify so those appointments
that are made tonight will go forward
the ones where there are vacancies the
monitoring officer has the authority to
appoint outside of the meeting
um so we can make any changes and then
get it ratified at the next council
meeting
[Applause]
you very much and that vote was carried
okay we now move to item 12
if I'm not mistaken
which is appointments appointment of
directors to the board
of BDC Suffolk Holdings Limited
and
the appointments councilor Mayberry
oh Madam chairman I thought you were
going to ask me to propose someone so
that's why I'm just responding to your
arm in the air I know I'm very quick in
that I was quick at school and I'm quick
still thank you
Okay so
are we going to ask
the latest news have you got the latest
names
you have
um
yeah
yeah okay so okay so we're good to go
um the suggested appointments are
councilor Busby
councilor Brian Riley councilor Deborah
saw and councilor John Ward
I'm still a Busby I invite you to
introduce the report
s that we uh go to the vote for those
four people is the Holdings board
directors yeah and I hope you enjoy the
training
a second of please
councilor Mayberry thank you very much
and again we need a show of hands in
favor
okay
that's carried I'm happy to say
now it's item 13. the appointment of
counselors to the shared revenues
partnership joints committee
now the nominations have been tabled
therefore could I have a proposer please
counselor Mabry Madam chairman I
actually have a question for this
because
um councilor Busby in
right a as leader has not actually
identified his account
calendar item 30 and I hope all
councilors see that
we are asked to appoint two cabinet
members and two substitutes and I'm
assuming and I hope our launching off a
second concern that they should all be
cabinet members
thank you
absolutely so my my question is
so sorry I interrupted um you um my
question is how can we appoint them if
we don't know who's in the cabinet and
absolutely because it hasn't been
advertised so that may have to be
something that um cannot be decided to
note exactly it has to be adjourned
thank you or whatever
decision anyway so it doesn't matter
yes so so chair just to explain it's the
leaders prerogative to appoint the
cabinet so um it's up to the leader when
he announces that it doesn't have to be
tonight he can announce that at any time
these are the nominations that we have
so
um unless the leader wants to announce
we can propose we can
delay or if you want to enact your
cabinet members then we can go ahead
be shame to have all the excitement in
one evening I think
and I'm going to come back and everybody
knows the position of my group but
councilor Busby if you would like to put
me on that committee I would love to and
if that means I have to come and talk to
you very nicely then perhaps
take more than talk
say and I
and I um
I will not put up with any right board
comments and I know that's said ingest
I know it was said ingest but I have
said because I have suffered from this
in the past I will not put up with it
and I hope the monitoring officer has
listened to me thank you okay thank you
very much councilor maybe moving on is
number item 14 appointments to Suffolk
joint Standards Board
these nominations have been tabled and
again can I have a proposer please
councilor Lee Parker and a seconder
counselor plum
again we will carry out the voting by a
show of hands
all in favor please
that's
carried
item six
item 15 appointments to the Joint Gypsy
and traveler Steering group
cancel you're being asked to appoint
four counselors to the Joint Gypsy and
traveler Steering group
nominations have been tabled therefore
can I have a proposer
councilor Jameson posing who's seconding
feel like an Auctioneer yes
councilor register thank you very much
um Madam chairman thank you
um we are a very select group and I'm
afraid at this moment in time we do not
have anyone who can sit on this
committee but of course if it change
changes I will inform the leader thank
you
thank you very much
so we currently have one nomination
and therefore I'd like a show of hands
please
we've got three nominated
Ruth Henry Allison Owen and Glee Parker
taking on them on block can I please
have
I've had to propose in a second have I
not had a Prius I have Lee Jameson
proposed yeah sorry yeah and councilor
Parker
yeah
so who's second is
councilor register right okay
so now we can take a show of hands
in favor
cue
item 16 is appointment Council working
groups
okay
sorry I'm being picked up on the detail
I have to confirm that the
aforementioned three nominees
have now been
a
appointed thank you
Council working groups Council you're
asked to appoint councilors to the
following working groups as tabled
each individual
um
chairman Jan has had a very exciting two
days and I'm sure she needs some sleep
apart from anything else after the
lengthy time she's had but there is an
Omission under the Constitution working
group and that is for me to be on that
as well thank you
right
well I read the
read each one individually
for a Clarity because okay for clarity
groups I'll read out the name of the
group
and then I'll read out the nominees
and then we'll go to a vote on block
councilor Jameson
yes
was put forward for
the community governance review working
group so
that's the first one
um
thanks
okay Community governance review working
group
is myself
councilor Parker and councilor
Carruthers
the Constitution working group
is councilor Jameson councilor Busby
Council award and councilor mibri
member Learning and Development working
group
councilor Dowling councilor McGraw and
councilor Huron
councilor Mabry
um yes
um I
um I'm looking at my group I'm actually
going to put myself on that
been coming to me yes I will advise
myself to that one as well as there is
the one I've just said okay thank you
thank you local plan working group
Sally Davis Helen Davis Council award
and counselor Holt
could I please have your show of hands
in favor for all those that have read
out
anonymous
it's been carried
oh my God
that's number 16.
item 17 questions by the public in
accordance with the council the
council's procedure rule 12 none
received can item 18 questions by
counselors in accordance with the
council rule their procedure Rule 13
none received I therefore
like to inform you that the next meeting
is Tuesday 20th of June at 5 30 pm
and before I close the meeting I would
like to invite everyone to the annual
Council present long service
presentation Awards which are being held
downstairs in the Frank room and I now
declare this meeting closed
thank you very much for your